zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
russische angriffe fast überall in der
ukraine vor allem auf die infrastruktur
wie zb eisenbahnlinien das ist der tag
heute vor allem aber wird immer
deutlicher wie groß der horror für die
eingeschlossenen zivilisten im as of
style werk in der nähe von mario pohl
war und noch ist denn auch wenn mehr als
100 gerettet werden konnten sind trotz
neuer kämpfe immer noch offenbar frauen
und kinder dort eingeschlossen über die
lage dort sprechen wir mit christoph
hanna vom internationalen komitee des
roten kreuz hunger sie waren an einer
evakuierungsaktion oder an verschiedenen
evakuierungsaktionen und versuchen
selbst beteiligt und sie sind in sapporo
wir schauen damit wir genau das
lokalisieren können uns mal gemeinsam
die karte an wir sehen hier im süden in
mariupol das stahl werks oft wir sehen
die östlichen gebiete in denen die
geretteten zunächst gebracht wurden und
dann eben von dort weiter etwa 200
kilometer nordwestlich nach sapori cia
dort sind also viele der aus dem
stahlwerk geretteten menschen inzwischen
in sicherheit und dort sind auch sie was
können sie berichten wie geht es den
menschen der schönen guten abend
natürlich ist es erst mal eine sehr
heikle schwierige operation die fünf
tage gedauert hat unsere kollegen sind
am freitag aufgebrochen um zivilisten
aus dem us-staat stahlberg zu evakuieren
und wir waren erfolgreich wir haben
gestern quasi mehr als 100 personen
retten können die zivilisten frauen
kinder waren und die gestern eben ins
labor angekommen sind diese leute sind
extrem traumatisiert sie müssen sich das
vorstellen diese personen haben diese
zivilisten haben mehrere wochen des
tageslicht nicht gesehen und wussten
überhaupt nicht was um sie herum
passiert außer dass das sie ja die die
geräusche der kämpfe gehört haben und
das ist natürlich eine extrem schwierige
situation die die die menschen sind
extrem thematisiert und brauchen
natürlich jetzt neben der der schnell
die hilfe der medizinischen hilfe
natürlich auch seelische betreuung wir
sehen die die bilder busse mit denen die
menschen von dort in sicherheit gebracht
wurden und wir können auch gemeinsam mal
anhören mit einem mit einigen der
menschen konnten wir auch sprechen
im keller unten war es wirklich so dass
ich manchmal bereut habe ein kind zu
haben weil ich einfach emotional total
traurig war manchmal konnten wir nicht
einmal etwas zu essen geben
in unserem bunker waren 42 menschen
darunter kinder im alter von 12 15 16
und 17 jahren wir müssen sie raus holen
jetzt wo das stahlwerk unter beschuss
steht sie müssen gerettet werden ihr
habt keine vorstellung wie schrecklich
es dort ist als wir im dunklen bunker
waren und auf einmal fängt immer wieder
alles an zu wackeln und zu beben
ich kann es einfach nicht glauben zwei
monate in dunkelheit als wir im bus
saßen habe ich zu meinem mann gesagt
jetzt brauchen wir keine taschenlampe
mehr wenn wir auf toilette gehen und
keinen eimer oder eine tüte mehr
benutzen wir haben nie das sonnenlicht
gesehen und hatten solche angst
er das sind unvorstellbare berichte wie
werden die menschen jetzt konkret
betreut
also wenn sie sie haben ja jetzt eben
die die bilder gesehen die die die
menschen gehört das ist unfassbar das
trauma das passiert ist und was ganz
wichtig ist ist dass diese menschen
jetzt natürlich in sapporo aufgefangen
werden die als internationales komitee
vom roten kreuz wir haben natürlich bei
der bei der evakuierung geholfen aber
was jetzt natürlich wichtig ist dass
diese leute weil die menschen weiter
betreut werden durch seelische betreuung
dass die den menschen der unterkunft
bekommen und natürlich jetzt weiter ihr
nach einiger zeit versuchen ihr leben
wieder zu starten und ganz wichtig was
ich was sich heraus nehmen möchte ist
das
essen erfolg ist dass wir diese menschen
aus allein konfliktgebiet aus diesen
stahlberg heraus bringen konnten für
sehr schwierige operation
extrem viel verhandlungen dabei die
schwierig sind mit den konfliktparteien
aber es wichtig dass auch und das möchte
ich betonen dass ist möglich ist dass
das humanitäre völkerrecht das ist leben
rettet und das ist das quasi gestern
bewiesen wurde
sie haben wir kinder auch gleich im
detail noch mal darauf ein wie diese
verhandlungen gelaufen sind sie haben
auch vorhin eingangs berichtet dass das
so lange gedauert hat fünf tage wochen
hat es denn gelegen warum war das so
schwer diese menschen dort herauszuholen
also man muss sich das so vorstellen das
ist natürlich ein aktiver konflikt ist
und sich die lage
am boden in der realität natürlich sehr
schnell ändern kann wir müssen wir
müssen verhandeln wir müssen mit den
konfliktparteien verhandeln wir müssen
sicherstellen dass unser team sicher ist
dass die zivilisten die wir evakuieren
sicher sind und da kann natürlich in
einem aktiven konfliktgebiet sich sehr
viel sehr schnell ändern und das
bedeutet natürlich dass das dass das
eine sehr schwierige operation sein kann
die sich länger erstreckt als als es
geplant wurde und man auch sehr flexibel
sein muss und schnell reagieren muss ich
kann ihnen einfach nur ein beispiel
geben wenn man wenn man busse hat wenn
man ein konto hat der sehr lange es der
durch verschiedene verschiedene check
points muss und und die leute müssen zum
beispiel auch toiletten und und man weiß
nicht was hinter dem busch warte das
kann eventuell
eine landmine dort sein das ist
natürlich dann extrem schwierig für
diese menschen aber auch für unsere
teams die sicherheit zu gewährleisten
und das macht es natürlich dann umso
schwieriger und deswegen dauern solche
operation weil hat diese operation
speziell auch so lange gedauert
hunger hier gibt es ganz viel respekt
für sie aus dem aus dem chat aus der
community auf youtube finde ich zb von
beit jala respekt für alle helfer vor
ort und ein dickes rotes herz anonymus
schreibt respekt für herrn hunger und
alle helfer drei daumen hoch und ein
user hat eine frage zu dem was sie über
dem t shirt tragen vielleicht können sie
den userinnen und usern einmal erklären
ich nehme an das ist irgendein
kennzeichen ihrer organisation genau da
ist es das rote kreuz
und schon wissen wir bescheid und das
genau ich natürlich vor ort auch um ganz
klar zu zeigen zu welcher organisation
sie gehören das ist auch genau als
aspekt für sie genau was wichtig ist
dass dieses also ich trage das jetzt im
moment weil eventuell es kann ja wir
eventuell in ein paar minuten los müssen
und das ist dient der identifizierung
dass ich mitarbeiter des internationalen
komitees vom roten kreuz bin und das ist
natürlich ein schutz symbol seit sehr
langer zeit um quasi hilfsorganisationen
wie dem roten kreuz neben das dass diese
organisation neutral ist dass diese
organisationen humanitäre hilfe leisten
kann um quasi auch unsere mitarbeiter
dem dort zu schützen aber sie auch klar
zu identifizieren
wenn ihr und sie weitere fragen oder
andere fragen an herrn hunger hat dann
tut das bitte sehr gerne wie gehabt über
die kommentarspalten oder wenn ihr die
app nutzt über e-mail an zdf heute -
live at zdf.de die e mail adresse wird
auch gerade eingeblendet herr hunger sie
sind natürlich mit ihrer it
organisationen solche rettungsaktionen
gewöhnt das ist quasi ihr ihr
kerngeschäft auch zivilisten in
kriegsgebieten zu schützen und zu retten
aber was macht diese situation vor ort
so
so besonders
also es ist natürlich so was wie sie es
beschrieben haben also wenn wir in der
lage sind zivilisten aus schwierige aus
schwierigen konflikt gebieten zu
evakuieren zu retten ist es natürlich
etwas das dass das sehr wichtig ist weil
das leben rettet
weil es auch zeigt wie wichtig die
arbeit von von organisationen wie dem
ikk ist hier würde ich sagen was was
sehr speziell ist ist dass die die
verhandlung sehr schwierig sind das ist
auch sehr schwierig ist diese leute zu
erreichen indem in dem am samstag
stahlberg und das natürlich die die nach
wie vor menschen dort unsere hilfe
brauchen und das ist nicht nur so hier
also quasi hier vor ort aber auch in
anderen gebieten der ukraine der fall
und meine nachricht ist auch an an
dieser menschen dass wir diese menschen
nicht vergessen haben und dass wir
versuchen diese menschen zu helfen dass
wir versuchen den leuten die
eingeschlossen sind dass wir ihnen zu
hilfe kommen und dass wir quasi durch
unsere arbeit als neutraler vermittler
in kriegsgebieten ebenso solche
hilfsaktionen durchführen können nun ist
die lage vor ort unübersichtlich wir
hören es gibt kämpfe es gab zunächst
berichte dass russische truppen im
gelände seien auch im gebäude sein das
wurde jetzt vom ukrainischen generalstab
zurückgewiesen das heißt es sei den
russischen truppen bisher nicht gelungen
in das gebäude einzudringen aber das ist
natürlich von hier sehr sehr schwer zu
beurteilen die lage rund um die kämpfe
und auch um die situation der menschen
noch vor ort fasst moritz neues mal für
uns zusammen
seit tagen und wochen hatten sie die
sonne nicht gesehen in bunkern
ausgeharrt jetzt endlich ein wenig
sicherheit mehr als 150 frauen kinder
und ältere menschen aus dem umkämpften
stahlwerk und der stadt mariupol konnten
gestern nach saab orissa gebracht werden
die kinder sind wie zombies es gab kein
tageslicht alle haben angefangen zu
husten haben sich schlecht gefühlt es
war sehr schwer in unserem bunker waren
30 menschen darunter neun kinder wir
wurden gerettet aber es sind immer noch
viele im stahlwerk
heute sind weitere evakuierungen aus
mariupol geplant das stahlwerk
allerdings steht unter beschuss im
fernsehen äußert sich der bürgermeister
von mario pohl besorgt
leider ist es war heute finden harte
kämpfe auf dem territorium des asus
stahlwerks statt unsere tapferen männer
verteidigen es aber es ist sehr hart es
wird beschossen mit schwerer artillerie
panzern und auch aus der luft vom schiff
aus wird die festung auch getroffen
inzwischen sagt er sei der kontakt zu
den ukrainischen truppen im stahlwerk
abgerissen
haha was wissen sie über die situation
vor ort wie haben sie kontakt zu den
menschen die da noch eingeschlossen sind
also wie natürlich der bericht gezeigt
hat ist die lage extrem unübersichtlich
was wir wissen ist dass nach wie vor
zivilisten dort hilfe brauchen und die
arbeit mit hochdruck natürlich daran
dass wir eventuell mehr leuten helfen
können mehr leute in sicherheit bringen
können gerade zivilisten gerade frauen
gerade kinder
die die natürlich die ambulanzen sind in
solchen situationen zur lage im
stahlwerk habe ich keine näheren
informationen im moment nicht teilen
kann aber natürlich sind wir daran wenn
zivilisten in solchen gebieten in
schwierigen situationen sind wirklich
situationen die die wirklich höllisch
sind das so haben das ja manche leute
beschrieben dort in dem in dem stahlwerk
versuchen wir natürlich alles um diese
leute in sicherheit zu bringen
eine letzte frage noch zu mariupol dort
haben wir vom roten kreuz anfang der
woche gehört das war quasi ein hilferuf
da hieß es man kommt nicht in die stadt
hinein man kann keine medizinischen
unterstützung keine medikamente liefern
wasser nahrung es fehlt an vielem was
sind ihre informationen wie es die lage
in mariupol in der stadt also natürlich
ist die lage schlimm weil natürlich nach
wie vor ein konflikt tobt was wichtig
ist ist dass wir durch diese kooperation
zum ersten mal zugang zum mario pohl
hatten wie haben wir mussten leider
mario kohle zu beginn des konfliktes
verlassen aber zum ersten mal sind wir
jetzt wieder dort gewesen haben diese
zivilisten in sicherheit gebracht und
was diese zivilisten und auch unsere
kollegen berichtet haben ist natürlich
dass die stadt ja extrem zerstört ist
und natürlich brauchen jetzt menschen
verschiedene humanitäre hilfe aber das
geht natürlich von den direkten
hilfsmaßnahmen geht das natürlich weiter
weitaus hinaus als wir haben zum
beispiel in anderen gebieten der ukraine
damit geholfen dass wir das wasser
netzwerk wieder anschließen dass wir
leuten dass wir leute psychologisch
betreuen und das sind natürlich sachen
da da da arbeiten wir mit mit anderen
roten kreuz partnern wie zum beispiel
auf dem deutschen roten kreuz zusammen
um eben leuten und den moscheen der
ukraine ein gewisses gewisse normalität
nach solchen schlimmen ereignis leben
zurückzugeben
hanna ich berichte kommen jetzt so viele
fragen dass ich doch gern ich weiß wir
müssen weg aber auf eine würde ich gerne
doch noch versuchen unterzubringen weil
das interesse ist groß ist und deshalb
auch wirklich schwierig ist direkt aus
erster hand wie jetzt von ihnen zu
erfahren was vor ort gemacht wird es
gibt ja viele meldungen rund um diese
evakuierungen und hier fragt ein user
namens cola erbse in spe mit 2 ich
verstehe das nicht so ganz die menschen
hatten doch vor wochen die möglichkeit
das werk zu verlassen warum sind sie
nicht gegangen
es ist natürlich ist eine sehr gute
frage was was was glaube ich wichtig ist
ist zu verstehen dass das in einem
konflikt dass das vieles unübersichtlich
ist dass menschen eventuell einfach nur
sicherheit und schutz suchen und wenn
man das stahlwerk nicht verlassen möchte
weil man nicht kann das ist auch etwas
was wir als als als rotes kreuz sehen
ist dass wir uns um die leute kümmern
müssen die nicht fliegen können die
alten die leute die die bleiben möchten
und die müssen wir auch erreichen und es
kann natürlich sein dass viele menschen
sicherheit gesucht haben viele menschen
haben sich nicht eventuell nicht aus
diesem stahl werk heraus getraut weil
sie eventuell befürchtet hatten
befürchtet haben dass der konflikt
wieder aus bringen könnte das kind
wieder ausbrechen könnte könnten und das
ist natürlich solche überlegungen in
solchen extremen situationen passieren
und und das sind dafür muss man
natürlich auch verständnis haben und
deswegen versuchen wir dann solchen
menschen die die eventuell nicht konnten
die eventuell nicht fliegen konnten oder
nicht wollte neben ja ein sicheres
geleit eben zu gewährleisten vielen dank
christoph hammer vom internationalen
komitee des roten kreuzes und ein paar
der kommentare die ihre große
unterstützung ausdrücken habe ich ihnen
ja schon vorlesen können seien sie
versichert hier gibt es noch sehr viel
mehr davon hier gibt es sehr großen
support und sehr große dankbarkeit für
ihre arbeit und vielen dank dass sie bei
uns in der sendung waren vielen dank
tja und nicht nur im südosten in diesem
gebiet gibt es kämpfe sondern heute
melden viele gebiete aus der ukraine
angriffe vor allem auf infrastruktur wie
zum beispiel
eisenbahnlinien und auch hier versuchen
wir einen kurzen überblick zu geben
lemberg im westen der ukraine ein
umspannwerk steht in flammen gestern
abend wurde die stadt von mehreren
explosionen erschüttert das ziel die
infrastruktur der bahn lahm zu legen
die raketen haben die stromversorgung
der bahn getroffen der angriff galt dem
nachschub von waffen aber auch von
hilfsgütern aus dem westen in den osten
auch im osten selbst hat es wieder
russische angriffe gegeben auch hier
sollte offenbar die infrastruktur
geschwächt werden ein öllager in der
region donetsk steht in flammen
raketenangriffe werden auch aus dem
zentrum und dem südwesten der ukraine
gemeldet
tja und damit gehen wir zu katrin
eigendorf nach kiew kathrin was spürt
man in der hauptstadt von denen
angriffen auf die gebiete in ganzen ja
im ganzen land muss man sagen
ja hier in der hauptstadt ist die
situation momentan relativ ruhig aber
natürlich sind hier sehr sehr viele
menschen die zum beispiel auch
angehörige in den heftig umkämpften
gebieten haben menschen die auch von
dort geflüchtet sind sie zum beispiel
gestern auf dem majdan auf dem zentralen
platz in kiew eine versammlung
demonstration gegeben von menschen die
angehörige in mario pohl haben die
darauf hinweisen wollten wie die lage
ihrer angehörigen sind ist also das sind
auf der einen seite soldaten gewesen
also menschen die ihre angehörigen dort
an der front haben teile der soldaten
sind eben auch eingesperrt in diesem
mass of stahlwerke sind aber auch
menschen die angehörige in der stadt
hatten und die uns wirklich teilweise
sehr sehr erschütternde geschichten
erzählt haben dass sie sich sehr große
sorgen machen ob sie ihre angehörigen
überhaupt nochmal lebendig wiedersehen
weil wir haben es ja gerade gehört die
evakuierung von zivilisten aus mario
pohl gestaltet sich entsprechend
schwierig
es ist immer mit dem großen risiko
verbunden dann doch unter beschuss zu
geraten wir wissen auch gar nicht genau
wie ist jetzt die lage momentan im
stahlwerk für die menschen die dort noch
sind und das sind immer so kleine
geschichten die wir hören und wenn man
die zu einem gesamtbild zusammenfügt
dann machen ist besteht wirklich großer
großer grund zur sorge für die situation
der menschen also es fehlt dort
teilweise an medikamenten an vernünftige
versorgung
menschen sind auch traumatisiert
das sind so die berichte die wir hören
das wurde ja jetzt gerade auch nochmal
bestätigt dass für russland mario pohl
eine doch sehr sehr wichtige rolle
spielt und deswegen geht man jeder von
auch aus dass dort obwohl jetzt dieser
zustand war dass man zivilisten
evakuieren konnte die kämpfe noch mal
deutlich zunehmen und das ist ja auch
fakt dass das passiert es gibt eine
frage von arabella eike bei youtube sie
fragt was wird mit den us auf kämpfern
geschehen
ja das wissen wir nicht also wir haben
mit angehörigen gesprochen die auch
frauen und mütter von azoff kämpfern
waren da und die machen sich große
sorgen also sagen wir mal wenn diese
diese kämpfer wirklich in russische
gefangenschaft
geraten oder von russland aufgespürt
werden wenn russland ist schafft dort
dieses stahlwerk einzunehmen wir haben
das erlebt es sind schwere
kriegsverbrechen die möglicherweise da
drohen es sind ja auch schon kämpfern
exekutiert worden das wird ja im moment
alles untersucht die kriegsverbrechen
die vermeintlichen die russland hier
begangen hat also meine prognose ist
das könnte für die sehr sehr riskant
werden
es gibt das sehe ich auch hier im chat
und das ist auch teil der der der ja
also wer sich damit beschäftigt stellt
auch manchmal im sinne putin stadt
propaganda vielleicht die frage ob die
zivilisten dort freiwillig sind oder wie
behauptet wird ob sie dort fest halten
werden von azoff kämpfern als
menschliche schutzschilde und sie gerne
das gelände verlassen würden aber das
eben nicht können weil sie von
ukrainischer seite daran gehindert
werden kannst du das einordnen
ich bin natürlich nicht vor ort aber ich
habe das in den vielen jahren die ich
über diesen konflikt berichte und ich
tue das schon seit 2014 diese behauptung
immer wieder gehört von russischer seite
dass die ukraine zivilisten als
menschliche schutzschilde benutzen habe
ich nie bestätigt gefunden das ist ja
auch das problem der russischen
propaganda und desinformation es werden
hier permanent behauptungen in die welt
gesetzt für die aber nie beweise und
nicht einmal belege angeführt werden
können sondern man versucht im prinzip
immer wieder die öffentlichkeit mit
diesen des informationskampagnen zu
irritieren zweifel zu säen auch an der
ukrainischen seite wie gesagt ich bin
nicht vor ort aber ich kann mir das
nicht vorstellen aus all den erfahrungen
die ich hier in der berichterstattung
aus diesem krieg der ja nun schon acht
jahre dauert ich kann das nicht
bestätigen ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen
es gibt auch viele fragen dazu was das
off regiment denn eigentlich ist und
dann liest man immer wieder das sind die
nazis jetzt erleben wir dass dieser
begriff in diesem konflikt von allen
möglichen seiten in verschiedensten
zusammenhängen gebraucht wird aber ich
weiß du hast dich auch mit dieser frage
schon sehr eingehend beschäftigt also
kannst du uns bitte noch mal aufklären
was ist das oft regiment wer sind die
azoff kämpfer
also zunächst einmal dieses argument
wird nicht von allen seiten angeführt
sondern das ist ein klassisches
russisches argument alle feinde
russlands werden immer als nazis
bezeichnet und die russen bezeichnen
denn nicht nur das als of regiment
sondern auch die ukrainische regierung
als nazis
um das zu erklären müssen ein bisschen
zurück gucken in die geschichte
2014 nach dem europa dann hat russland
die krim besetzt hat russland angefangen
krieg gegen den osten der ukraine zu
führen
die armee war damals die ukrainische
armee war damals mit diesen griffin sehr
sehr überfordert sie war gar nicht gut
genug aufgestellt um die abzuwehren das
waren ja im prinzip angriffe die auf
separatisten im osten der ukraine gebaut
haben aber natürlich maßgeblich von
russischen militärs durchgeführt wurden
da haben sich im prinzip hier muss man
sich vorstellen in der ukraine
freiwilligen bataillone gebildet das
kann man so beschreiben das sind im
prinzip selbst organisierte miliz
gewesen die haben sich selber waffen
gekauft die haben sich selber
zusammengeschlossen und sind dann
einfach an die front gezogen und haben
dort gekämpft und eine dieser bataillon
er ist eben dass es oft bataillon es
gilt als eines der radikalsten
sicherlich extrem nationalistischen
bataillonen ist auch hier im land sehr
sehr umstritten weil eben rechtsextremen
einzuordnen es gab auch andere
bataillone die wesentlich samer
gemäßigter waren aber natürlich sind es
vor allem glühende nationalisten gewesen
die hier zu den waffen gegriffen haben
und an die front gezogen sind und dass
es oft bataillon hat sich vor allem im
kampf um mario pohl und in den angriffen
und mario pohl im sommer bekannt gemacht
weil sie haben diese angriffe der russen
dort 2014 aufgehalten
es gibt diese freiwilligen bataillone
mittlerweile nicht mehr sondern wir sind
eigentlich weitgehend integriert in die
armee und das ist auch der fall beim als
of bataillon so kann man das einordnen
vielen dank kathrin dann warten wir mal
zum abschluss noch den blick wir sehen
den neunter mai das ist ein besonderer
tag in russland wird er auf besondere
art und weise gefeiert nämlich als sieg
über nazi-deutschland und im vorfeld
dieses datums werden verschiedentlich
sorgen laut zum beispiel auch darüber
dass putin das zum angriff nehmen könnte
bestimmte gebiete im osten der ukraine
quasi sich einzuverleiben
das ist unter anderem die befürchtung
von michael carpenter er ist
amerikanischer botschafter bei der
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa osze und wir
mal ganz kurz in diesem forum ein
nach unseren neuesten informationen
glauben wir dass das land versuchen wir
die sogenannten volksrepublik bonn jetzt
und lohans zu annektieren nach unseren
informationen sind auch manipulierte
referenten über den anschluss an
russland mitte mai geplant ähnliche
pläne sieht moskau auf her sondern
betracht
katrin teilt man in kiew eine
ukrainischen regierung diese befürchtung
diese informationen gibt es auch hier
ist
papiere die gefunden worden sind die
wohl auch schon auf die organisation
eines referendums hindeuten davon geht
man aus weil du hast es ja gerade gesagt
der neunte mai ist für russland ein
wichtiger feiertag es ist der wichtigste
russische feiertag man feiert am 9 mai
den sieg über nazideutschland und alle
gehen davon aus dass putin an diesem tag
seiner eigenen bevölkerung und der
russischen elite etwas präsentieren muss
was darauf hindeutet dass russland
weiter an dieses negativ anknüpfen kann
biel sind die erfolgreichen kämpfer für
die befreiung der ukraine wir befreien
dieses land vom faschismus bisher hat
russland die ja keine großen erfolge
keine großen militärischen erfolge hier
vorzuweisen gehabt das heißt das feiern
der armee könnte entsprechend schwierig
werden an diesem tag denn das ist immer
damit auch verbunden
auch das narrativ von der befreiung der
ukrainischen bevölkerung geht nicht
wirklich auf denn die ukrainische
bevölkerung empfängt die russischen
soldaten empfängt die russische armee
nicht mit offenen armen sondern ganz im
gegenteil der widerstand ist erbittert
und wächst eigentlich mit jedem tag des
krieges weiter deswegen geht man davon
aus dass putin in irgendeiner form etwas
sammer der öffentlichkeit präsentieren
muss einmal vielleicht denkt man eine
weitere eskalation des krieges und dann
ist natürlich ein großes thema anschluss
der
sogenannten volksrepublik in lugansk und
dann jetzt wir teilweise schon von
separatisten beherrscht werden das man
im prinzip auch den bisher noch von kiew
kontrollierten teil noch mit annektiert
und damit russland
ein teil der ukraine sich weiter
einverleibt das ist durchaus eine option
mit der man hier in kiew rechnet und wir
müssen einfach abwarten was am 9 mai
passiert das ist in irgendeiner form
eine eskalation in die richtung geht die
der ukraine weiter schaden wird davon
gehe ich aus dann eine letzte frage an
dich über youtube fragt ein user namens
anonymous frau eigendorf glauben sie
noch an eine verhandlungslösung
das ist eine schwierige frage aber jeder
kriegt jeder konflikt wird letztendlich
in einer verhandlungslösung enden müssen
und das ist wird einfach die geschichte
anders kann man ihnen nicht beenden die
frage ist zu welchen konditionen und
dazu hat sich ja wohl immer
noch mal sehr klar geäußert dass es für
ihn hier ganz klare rote linien gibt
dass er nicht bereit ist einen frieden
mit russland zu schließen zur bedingung
land gegen frieden das ist ja etwas
worüber immer wieder geredet wird dass
die ukraine bereit ist die von russland
annektierten
halbinsel krim abzutreten dass die
ukraine sich möglicherweise bereit
erklärt auch teile des ostens an
russland abzutreten da sagt zielinski
das eine rote linie und die ukraine
haben dazu einen sehr klaren standpunkt
und sagen russland muss seine truppen
hier abziehen russland kann muss die
souveränität der ukraine achten das
heißt beide seiten sind noch sehr sehr
sehr weit voneinander entfernt ich sehe
jetzt nicht in kürze dass wir hier zu
einer verhandlungslösung kommen aber es
wird sie irgendwann geben und die frage
ist da wer ist in welcher position
und ja wie kann eine nachkriegsordnung
für die ukraine aussehen und wie sieht
dann auch russland aus
ein weit in die zukunft gerichtete
ausblick am ende dieses live streams
vielen dank katrin eigendorf für die
einschätzungen live aus kiew und danke
liebe userinnen und user fürs mit
kommentieren und fragen stellen und
damit sagen wir hier tschüss bis zum
nächsten mal